[Music]
from thin and wispy to big and puffy
clouds cover about 70 of the planet at
any given moment
but what if in the next minute
they all disappeared that incident might
shock on on-looking astronauts on the
space station
but someone who is say hiking in the
desert
wouldn't know right away that things on
earth were about to get
really bad within a few days though the
first warning sign would show up
humidity it'll be even worse if you live
by the coast
normally the sun's heat evaporates water
mostly from the ocean
and that water vapor is condensed into
clouds
but if clouds are cut out of the earth's
water cycle that water just
hangs around in the air creating close
to 100
humidity if you were to get on a flight
you might experience more turbulence
than usual
without the protective cover of clouds
to bounce sunlight into space
the sun will heat the earth more
creating more rising uneven hot air
but a bad flight may be the least of our
worries because there will be no more
rain
or snow or even a light mist and that
means there won't be any way to
replenish the water sources we drink
from
like lakes streams rivers springs and
aquifers
so once last winter's snow melts we're
stuck with whatever water we have on
hand
and the clock is ticking if the world
were to keep up its current water
consumption rate
we would drain all of the fresh water
lakes and rivers in about 23 years
so to conserve our fresh water supply
humanity will have to be strategic
today the average american uses about 80
to 100 gallons of water every day
but saving ourselves is going to take
more than just skipping long
showers and laundry the water we use in
our home and public places accounts for
only 21
of our water usage the two biggest
demands are actually thermoelectric
power to generate electricity
and irrigation for farms not only do
power plants use tons of water
ones that run on nuclear fuel could
spell disaster
if their water cooling towers run dry
the 2011 fukushima nuclear disaster for
example
was set off when an earthquake knocked
out power to its water cooling pumps
and farms are going to need even more
water without the help of a good rain
this permanent drought would kill tons
of wild vegetation and animals as the
land dries
up within a few years eroding soil may
kick up
giant dust storms like the dust bowl in
the 1930s
meanwhile earth's climate will be going
haywire without clouds
it's hard to say when this will all
happen without some very expensive
climate modeling the cloud expert chris
farrell did offer some quick back of the
envelope calculations
without clouds average surface
temperatures would rise by as much as
22 degrees celsius this extreme
temperature spike would not only destroy
the habitats of most flora and fauna
killing off whatever survived the
drought it would also melt the polar ice
caps and cause
massive flooding of coastal cities you
might end up being part of the 40
of the world that would be forced inland
and your new home might soon be in an
endless desert as seawater starts
seeping into our fresh and precious
groundwater
sounds alarming but there are some
silver linings to a world without clouds
no more devastating hurricanes and
tornadoes or delayed flights because of
stormy weather
or cloudy skies to ruin your stargazing
as the water supply dwindles we'll have
to make some hard choices
but hey humans are creative we could
invent ways to desalinate ocean water
or collect all that water vapor from the
air and the sooner we do it
the better because in reality we're
already losing clouds
unprecedented levels of co2 and the
warming oceans and atmosphere
are all causing clouds to thin out so
despite the silver linings
it might be best to reduce our
greenhouse gas emissions and try to
avoid this scary new world
[Music]
entirely
you